hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm going to
check out a video from screen junkies
one of my favorite YouTube channels out
there the honest trailer for one of my
for sure top two favorite movies it's
either the matrix with Terminator 2 i
fluctuate between them Terminator 2 your
Judgment Day honest trailer decided to
see what they say I [ __ ] love this
movie I don't think it's like perfect
but they perfected a lot of things I'll
put it like that in the grand tradition
of r2d2 the Iron Giant and Charlie 5
comes another adorable kid in their pet
robot story only this one's king at
Ted's
in Terminator 2 Judgment Day done doctor
done - done - done
return - era when hard our fields were
sold to children you're next
Jordan corner be stopped baby I thought
when I was three years old he probably
weren't ready to see and would have been
even more disturbing even started the
studio's first choice Oh Jay Simpson Oh
journey to a future so grim the streets
are literally paid with human skulls as
the evil AI Skynet sends a terminator
back in time to kill John Connor whose
father was a man sent back in time to
protect him meaning if the robots really
wanted to kill John
they shouldn't have sent anything to
kill it at all since he never would have
been born when a Skynet doesn't send
back the first generator who wouldn't
leave and the technology that led this
Skynet existing in the first place yeah
the timelines off go and it is eat the
t1000 the iPhone of killer cyborg whose
liquid metal body can take any shape
meaning those ears were a deliberate
choice and the t85 indestructible nokia
brick load of killer cyborgs a stiff
emotionless monotone giant that Arnold
Schwarzenegger was born to play
of awesome features like shaka whirling
and endless supply of one-liners I'll be
back
come with me if you want the hasta la
vista baby a casualty counter that's
specific down to the decimal point for
some reason and detailed files on human
anatomy I've to tell fouls on human
atoms except for crying what's wrong
with guys or smiling watch these killers
spend the first third of the film in a
cat-and-mouse game that would have you
guessing which one is the good guy
if the trailers hadn't already given it
away he was ready to destroy the future
now his mission that foundation is to
protect it a lesson
we still haven't learned apparently what
did they done to my son serve I was what
you told me had thrilled as they track
down the Conner family Sarah the che
guevara of soccer moms with some big
guns and some big guns and John Hurt
nine-year-old son played by Edward
Furlong who would go on to star in
numerous court appearances did you call
uh-huh
yes so witness an amazing filled with
horrible consequences that spawned a
thousand lazy pop-culture references
who's that hasta la vista
hasta LaVista Jesse hasta LaVista baby
turned Arne into a screw-up of
themselves
I'll be back back I'll be back I might
be back I'll be back I'm dark so dark
how back I'm not going to say that give
you a say and let the film industry to
overvalue sequels stars and CGI that
still doesn't look much better today
when all you really want is a good story
about a hero who sacrifices himself to
save humanity even if it means leaving
behind the only people who ever loved
him
what no I'm not crying why did he cry
dumb stupid action movie stop looking at
me I cry like every story so much
promise I earn miles Dyson
Budnick Alex mattock Hey Arnold Guns and
Roses good in roses hop the only Sarah
Connor wasn't in Game of Thrones Hank
from Breaking Bad no really
and the FA's a terminator too bad they
kept making sequels you know I'm all for
self-sacrifice and everything but you
know you left your arm back in the
factory right that's the exact same
mistake they made at the end of the
first 100 job be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers I'll be back the
day epic voice guy read one of your
comments was the most important day of
your life but for me it was Tuesday dark
learn che che che
I ate my brother's turtle victory is my
destiny for the watch okay okay well
done honest trailers they didn't say the
movie was bad you know it's just cool
because everyone knows from ear to
[ __ ] rocks but there are some
problems when Arnold does leave his arm
behind I actually never thought of that
until now like that is so true that was
the thing that caused Skynet to start
coming into existence all over again the
timeline is very [ __ ] up to me I have
the hardest time getting this point
across but when I get this point across
when someone finally understands what it
is I'm trying to say they sort of agree
with me okay here's one okay let me try
this out you got a look at the way how
it went from timeline and then how the
timeline looped into the past and then
change the course of the future okay I
know it sounds [ __ ] weird but here's
all that happens before anyone was sent
back through time Sarah Connor gets
pregnant we don't know who it it can't
have been Kyle Reese because Kyle Reese
is from the future so if Kyle Reese is
from the future
that means Sarah Connors original John
Connor kid must have been a different
daddy Sarah Connor has a kid terminators
come into existence
rebels form and John Connor leads the
rebels John Connor finds out whoa
they're sending someone back in time to
kill my mother they're sending a
terminator back in time to kill my mom
so John Connor goes okay I'm gonna send
back a guy who is probably younger than
me named Kyle Reese to go save my mom he
ends up [ __ ] Sarah Connor and then
she names the kid John Connor
but that wasn't originally Kyle Reese's
baby it couldn't have been because Kyle
Reese is from the future so it was
someone else's child but he's supposed
to go down the same future because
Sarah's is telling this brand-new kid he
has to I don't know but it that's just
like my nitpicky thing is kind of
nitpicky
kind of a big deal but whatever you know
like I know that oh the twist is that
Kyle Reese is really his dad but that
just doesn't make any sense to me it
would it's a that means the kid of Kyle
Reese is a different John Connor than
the John Connor who sent Kyle Reese back
in time but Terminator 2 seriously one
of my favorite movies besides that I
always let that go it's still one of the
best movies I've ever seen I love it
Arnold's best performance I think he's
does more than just be like monotone
like there's actually some depth to the
role that he provided I really noticed
it the last time I watched it I just
introduced it to Veronica I think it's a
badass flick [ __ ] love it if you guys
are new to the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
where if we get enough followers we can
get more product placement that means a
[ __ ] ton more cash for me no real
benefit for you
Greg coated Gomez jr. I like the name
Greg Greg is a good name every Greg I
know is [ __ ] worthy just want to point
that out
hey Ryan love your YouTube videos became
a huge fan keep the magic happening it'd
be awesome to get a shout-out sure thing
Greg coated Gomez jr. Greg is just it
means vigilant and watchful I know a lot
about that name Greg and you definitely
look vigilant and watchful I'm not going
to show people a picture you but you
look like a kind of pervy vigilant and
watchful like you're stalking a woman
and it's all you're gonna take advantage
of you're not going like raper or
something but it looks like you will
kill her though kind of like the movie
maniac where he scalps those woman you
look like the scalping type of Greg and
if your name is Greg it's okay then if
you want to scalp some [ __ ] go for it
they probably deserve to be scalped